Này 1 chỉ nắm mấy một, các quan hàn không, đi bằng Mỹ, F-A, Thục Báo, đình chỉ quan bộ hạt động của sống
mấy bây trở hàng mơ đây, mấy một và mơ đây, mấy một F, để vụ vụ kiểm tra ký thuật.
Sau vụ, tanya nêm trọng tại bàn khán chất kì người mùng 1 thích một.
Theo các quan này, chứ mấy bài mắt ton nhau, cho Clas, mơ đây, mấy một của hàng apps.
Đã mất động cơ bên trái, chúng quả chính thích cánh.
Sa đến giờ, và bóc trái hình xin bài của tế, lối s vêu mua mắt, ali khi đến nhất mấy bốn người tiết mặt.
Cơ quan hàn không để bằng Mỹ, kìm báo, là điều kiện mất cả này của tế tôn tại,
ở các mấy bài khác cùng thiết kế, sau đó yêu cầu kiểm tra quan diện, chứ kì cho phép hoạt động,
trở lại. Bộ em là đừng bị sở rữ, mấy bài mắt cho nèo được LAS,
đạo quyền nghỉ các hẳng tạm dự kè cáng mở đây, một hàng apps và F-A, Thục Báo,
nường tuần bộ phí đổi để bảo đảm tạm bài.
Đi được xem là biển pháp mạnh tành nhất, quốc quán hàn không để bằng Mỹ,
tệ tụi nó màn yên không trên mấy bà, nhằm nân ngờ dùi dò trong lĩnh vực hàn không bận đàn.